bootleg cat podcast we got a legend in
here man no I'm not a legend bro you are
a legend no well look I grew up watching
you play basketball at a very high level
I'm 35.
so that was like my era you know what
I'm saying Lamar Odom is here man what's
good what's good bro it's crazy I just
uh
just so randomly like last week I was in
Phoenix at my parents house and I I um
I pulled a lot of my old [ __ ] out of
storage and I found um the Slam Magazine
cover with you and uh Darius miles and
was it cute rich on it was that one
brand that's right yeah yeah
legendary cover yeah that was my idea
too for us to um weigh each other's
jerseys and put them on backwards yeah
that was no color yeah that was a it's
crazy because like when you go back and
look at the roster of like those some of
those Clippers teams you were on
just so talented man just like it just
did I guess it didn't work out but [ __ ]
you guys had you guys are deep if we had
if that team would have had like
one can we hit the mic in front of you
oh yeah
if that team would have had like um like
one veteran yeah that was like
respecting the league that we could have
like learned from because everybody was
young good habits yeah yeah we just out
there hooping yeah it's crazy how
crazy was it back did you guys like when
you were playing for the Clippers did
you like know
much about Donald Sterling being like a
a [ __ ] or was it like you know I
mean I knew that he had the reputation
that he wasn't going
pay anybody
cheap yeah so
um
you know even though you're young and
you understand the business a little bit
at that point in time in your career I
kind of
knew that I wasn't probably going to be
there long because I knew that I was you
know good enough to be a
uh max pay player right and he wasn't
gonna he was a cheap owner yeah yeah he
knew the system on how to
[Music]
um
you know not
win games and still come up on a plus
side as far as making money because it
was like all about the bottom line with
him yeah so wow it's like why would we
spend money to win a championship I'm
making money at the end every year stay
shitty and draft players and yeah no
love for the game or for the brothers
obviously yeah obviously yeah